prosecutors in france have opened a
terrorism investigation after a police
employee was stabbed to death at a
police station near paris
the 48 year old administrative worker
was reportedly stabbed in the neck
by a man who was then shot and killed by
police at the scene
french president emmanuel macron said
his country would never
give in to what he called islamist
terrorism
a normally quiet residential area just
outside paris
now the center of attention in france
security agents
flooded the area investigating the
killing of a police employee
that occurred in an unlikely location
the police station is very well
protected there is a protective lock and
so people can't just walk in
so the attacker waited for her to go and
change her parking ticket
the murderer caught her by surprise as
she left the police station for just a
moment
and so it was really a cowardly barbaric
attack
to kill someone and to kill a
policewoman
local media report that the attacker was
a 36 year old man with no criminal
record
some witnesses say they heard him say
allahu akbar
arabic for god is great as he stabbed
his victim
a police officer then opened fire on the
attacker killing him
their suggestions the man had previously
scouted out the site
the office of the national
anti-terrorism prosecutor has taken
charge
over the investigation of the crimes
committed here
the reasons for this are first how the
events occurred
which involved looking for a target
also the way the crime was committed
the profile of the victim but also the
remarks made by the perpetrator
at the time of the crime
president emmanuel macron paid tribute
to the police worker
whom he identified as stephanie in a
tweet he said the nation stood by her
family
he added in the fight against islam is
terrorism
we will not give up islamist terrorism
is again a worry for france and even the
police
are a target
straight to parison where we join
journalist catherine
field welcome catherine um bring us up
to date what what more do we know
in the last few hours police have gone
into the
home of the assailant nafar from the
police station in hambury to the
southwest of paris
we also know that they're carrying out a
search of his previous home which is in
eastern paris
police have also taken into custody for
questioning
three of members of his close entourage
we understand one of those could be a
family
member in the meantime police also say
they have his
mobile phone they're going through that
to see what sort of links he may have
had
uh in the last few hours before this
attack took place
whether they were links to jihadist
organizations or
or anyone that can give them some sort
of clue
as to where this man was coming from
what he was doing
who were his accomplices if indeed there
were any because this is a
a man who was not known to the security
services he wasn't known to the
intelligence services
so they're really just fumbling around
at this moment to try and
put together a picture of what actually
happened in those
minutes before this attack took place
and this is now being treated as a
terror attack so what what difference
does that make in terms of powers of
arrest and the way that the
investigation is handled
it means that the anti-terror
prosecutors can call on the
french domestic intelligence unit it
means that they can
have much more wider scope will be able
to
draw in other witnesses they can hold
people for longer
and of course they have all this other
information to have that they've had
unfortunately from other attacks there's
been a spate
over the last five or six years of
attacks on
very small police stations and homes of
police officers
uh in the western paris area so they'll
be able to get all that information
together
very quickly and try and find out yet
once again
what went wrong that an armed attacker
was able to get
through the front door of a police
station and stabbed to death
a police employee and what sort of place
is rambu where this attack happened
it's a very quiet little suburban town
really it's about 60 kilometers
southwest of paris it has a
fast train service into the french
capital so the sort of people who live
there are generally
families you can have a very small house
with a little small garden
uh the area is also known for having a
beautiful
forest a lovely chateau it's where you
would really go
to get away from the sort of hustle and
bustle of the city and i think
that's why uh the scenes that we're
seeing tonight in rambia are just so
shocking because people are wandering
around the street saying
how could this have happened in this
quiet sleepy little commuter town
uh where everyone has always been known
for being friendly and law-abiding
thank you for that uh catherine
journalist catherine field in paris
thank you